sha sense hand workk on
I it's quite
unique so I've seen older videos where
he kind of did it very more common
way uh
but eventually he's
here so what is the difference these
hands are in different
planes in his hands same
plane same plane move out of the same
plane
see often
times uh some explanation is uh ion me
is the uh fixated movement equivalent of
the ballistic
shanci so he'd have the same hand
movement same
uh some justifications I've seen over
the years for shanci is that you kind
Let It Go it goes down
here uh taking Shi and going like this
hands in different planes you
see doesn't work as well so there's a a
a consistency being sought between ion
me the fixated movement equivalent of
the ballistic movement shanci
okay um looking at the technique his
line is
here this angle here the EDI angle
see the other angle is here see
so back leg here oriented towards his
spine other one over here oriented
towards here so here you can see the two
hands in different
planes hands in the same
plane
okay some other uh details uh to note
then is the entry is almost like
Tenon so when he
goes uh or but remember remember you
have Ido ten con too so I can
enter and then you have that little
adjustment that you
did I'll do it again so
enter and I take that angle and I got
off the line of attack
now the other one you stay on the line
of attack they see he didn't like
that however
what you soon
learn is that the outer
deltoid is
apparently being
engaged this way do you
see and it's a very weak muscle
group so people start to
go dominate on this hand
which is a big muscle group chest area
Okay and then what happens though is
your hands are not in the same plane
anymore you see you're all split up
here also when the elbow comes to
dominate The
Movement you now are no better off in
terms of staying on the line of attack
in terms of the attack is usually also
the line of their Mass which means it'll
be the line of the resistance so when I
come
around pushing That Elbow is pushing his
entire Mass you understand okay
so I got to move my body into the Emi
angle can't go can't go here
this
way there's all kinds of ways of moving
into that me angle I just did it with a
yield you see I didn't
enter Then you have it you in the 10
okay
um I have to figure out how to keep my
hands in the same plane to gain all the
benefits of that
because this is very open this is very
Compact and most fighting is compact you
don't you don't do that in real real
stuff
um there's a reason
why the deltoid is noted as being weak
which justifies the reason for the elbow
hand starting to dominate the technique
and it is
because it is done
externally only okay and when I go
external there's something else you'll
notice his elbow and his hand are in
different planes as mine are in
different planes so the fact that my
hands are in the same plane would have
to mean that his elbow and his wrist is
in the same plane so again my hands are
in different ples Al so is his elbow and
hand same thing I go over here same
thing his elbow and say his elbow and
hand are in different vertical
planes as my elbow and hand move out of
the way are in different planes
okay I don't want that he has a lot of
power still in that different planes
okay he can drop his elbow and
everything goes to crap
okay you might want to go but I'm so
strong I can shove everyone now okay
you're still doing a y yangong Clash
which is not iido and that is not
jiujitsu iido is a jiujitsu you're not
there to overpower someone okay so what
you have to learn is how to get his
elbow and wrist in the same plank same
plank
same
plane and what I do
that it's in the same
plane he's going his energy come up a
little in your energy his energy is
going to hit a Coq PA as it comes down
boom pay attention to my elbow hand if
it's pushing on him it's not even closed
usually
okay because I'm doing a CQ projection
the delto is not moving from the outside
of the inside so the outer delto is not
being utilized so I don't feel the
weakness of the outer deltoid I'm not
using the outer deltoid okay so pay
attention as we
go
so his path though has to
come down absorb his
energy and then up and you let him hit
that not
out
down down in a
circle but I'm not making a
circle with my deltoid but did
Circle where do you feel it or his grip
is that's where your cooku projection
initiates
then I
follow the
entering that I
generated so it's not that I push him
into
it I
project I stay with him as he projects
off so the elbow Han is not sh coming
down the elbow hand is resting lightly
on
[Music]
him let's try
uh a
common
fighting principle in the internal Arts
okay you're going to uh he's going to
come in okay and
here um
say already at this contact you see
already at this
contact uh I am not trying to pull out
his finger
fingers I'm
sticking inside his
grip do you understand so I'm not
pulling
him the right at the moment I don't want
to lift it up but I don't want him
pushing me down where he wants so I'm
not on the positive side and I'm not on
the negative side either I'm
at the middle zero and so when I do
that I now am going to get stuck to him
he's going to get stuck to me okay so
you kind of open your grip right and
this is the thing that I
move okay usually the beginner mistake
is they go away and they're pulling him
in you see an adhesion in
okay so you're going to stick you're
going to adhere and then you're going to
project okay and he's going away from
you
now you have to follow after the
projection so he projected he moved that
way so he made Yin space that allows for
my EDI which is Yang movement do you
understand but it's space cannot be
disconnected from time so when I go
here now there's not really in space
it's up for the it's up for grabs
because I didn't follow him and now I'm
going to do a new
movement can't do that with my
finger
so I have the connection Boom the
projection and I'm already here when he
hits that
spot not here when he hits that spot
okay so I
could done this is I wouldn't do that
the technique opening is
gone so you
project
you already
falling so
different you
see so you'll feel as he as his energy
hits here and it goes off it's going the
other way you follow to keep that
adhesion do you
understand
you can't wait there and allow the
separation okay try